(audience cheering)
- Your style is so cool.
- Thank you, thank you.
- You always, I feel
like every time I see you
or John Legend, y'all look so good.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- That's my brother, I love John.
- Yeah, you always, I know
y'all did Glory together,
but I just, every time I see either one
of you, I'm always like, I
should really work on my game.
Like, my ice and my threads.
- No, no, no, you got style.
- I just wear what people put me in.
- You know, people like see me out
and sometimes be like,
is that John Legend?
I'm like, no, it's - (chuckles)
- Oh, I don't think y'all
look anything alike.
- I know, I know, I know.
- I meant just how nice
y'all look all the time.
- Thank you, thank you.
- You always look so,
like together and dapper, it's nice yeah.
- I appreciate it.
- How is your 2024?
- It's beautiful.
- Yeah?
- I'm like, I came in
with a positive mindset in 2024.
- Yeah.
- 2023 was kind of
difficult in certain ways.
- Yeah.
- And 2024, I came in with
the right, with a clear mind.
I like bringing in the new year if I can,
like either in church or somewhere,
like in a solid place of solitude
with just my focus and intentions.
- Yeah.
- Oh, I loved it, yeah.
- Yeah, thank you.
(audience applauds)
- So, I heard that your
daughter just graduated,
is it law school?
- Yeah she-
- You raise them well.
- Yeah well-
- I'm like, oh, law school.
That's a minute, she
was there for a minute.
- She was there for a minute.
I was saying now-
- Beautiful.
Her name is Omoye and she's-
- You must be so proud.
- I'm super proud, and it's
like, she went to Howard School.
Howard University.
- Yeah.
- Historical black college,
went to Howard Law.
And now is working at a firm doing well.
It's, you know, it's tough,
but she's doing well.
- Yeah.
- It's well for me too,
I don't have any, I don't have
to pay any tuition, no rent.
(everyone laughs)
- She's good.
- That's amazing yeah.
- Yeah.
- And if you have any questions...
- Yeah, exactly.
- She can answer them.
- I definitely will put her
on the team at some point.
- Yeah.
- You know, I'm one of those people.
Like, I'm a tough dad though.
I'm like, you gotta earn your spot.
Of course I'm gonna help her
out and get her to places,
but I wanna-
- I think that's smart though, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, I want to-
- That's, oh, my kids all
the time are like, well,
we could just buy it.
And I go, "I could, you have no money."
- See that, that-
- You are poor.
- That is good, that is good parenting,
to me that is good parenting.
I'm like-
- No, because you gotta work for-
My daughter right now
at nine wants to work.
She's like, can I at least babysit?
Can I, she wants to-
I instilled in her like, like-
I take her to Target,
you're spending your Christmas money.
I buy you enough (beep).
I'm like, yeah, you got a
load of stuff I buy you.
You can buy this.
- Hey, Kelly, Kelly.
- Yeah.
- I rock with that.
- It's good for them.
- I like that.
Like that, that will get
our children out there
and they won't feel entitled.
You have to earn these things.
And also my mother made me do that
because it taught me to value things.
- Exactly.
- I was able to value like,
'cause it's, you know, as a
kid, at one point, as a kid,
she bought me a pair of drums.
A set of drums, 'cause I said
I wanted to be a drummer.
I was drumming, and after a few
weeks I busted a hole in the
drums and turned it
into a basketball hoop.
Like, and she like, "yo, you
don't even value what you got."
And like-
- Yeah.
- And I had to learn
the lessons eventually.
I wish I could drum now.
- Yeah.
- At least I'm a good basketball player.
- I can't, yeah, I'm neither one.
I can't play basketball
or drum, or keep a beat.
- You got talents, you
got a lot of talents.
- But like, not that.
We were both actually
raised by single parents.
- Yeah.
- I was for several years of my life.
And now I am one.
Like, what was your experience with that?
Because it's so hard.
I mean, watching my mom when
I was younger was one thing.
You're the kid, right?
But then becoming a single parent,
is like a whole other level
of understanding your parent.
- Well, I have a lot of reverence and love
and respect for my mother.
What she brought to me
as a single mother early on
in my life, she implanted
so many strong values in me
and just gave me the love,
like a full love while I didn't
know what, what I was missing.
And then she, I have to give it up.
My stepfather, his name is
Ralph, when she remarried,
she married a good man.
He was a man of-
- Wow.
- He is a man of good values
and a strong human being.
And they both had belief in God.
So all that like was-
- Poured into you.
- Those seeds, those
were seeds they planted.
So, look, I wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for the love
of my mother and the work
that Ralph put into me
and all my elders and and loved ones.
- Yeah.
- It's definitely a village,
I believe, yeah, yeah.
He's got a new book called,
"And Then We Rise,
A Guide to Loving and
Taking Care of Self."
So the title was influenced
by Maya Angelou, right?
- Yes, yes, Dr. Maya Angelou is one of my,
inspirations in life.
When I was in fifth grade,
she was the first writer I could remember.
Like loving her poems and her writing.
And you know, when I
was writing this book,
I was really thinking about, I entitled it
"And Then We Rise" because
I'm a believer in like,
the more we love ourselves,
the higher we get within
ourselves from the mind, the body,
the soul, the higher we
rise within ourselves,
the better we do for our communities.
Meaning, you know, without self-love,
you can't really-
- Give love.
- Give love as well as
you should be able to.
And I believe that we all deserve joy
and happiness and wellness.
And I just wanted to, I
wanted to write this book
as like a practical guide.
And it's not, it's really easy to read.
It's like me sharing the things
that I've experienced as far
as like the chef that I worked with,
just some recipes is in the book.
- Yeah.
- Workouts.
Today I worked out, I didn't
feel like working out,
but I just did it.
- Yeah.
- Because I needed, it's
part of my practice.
How do we work through some
of the fears, the hurts that we have?
I've used obviously
phys, I've used therapy.
- Yeah, me too.
- Like, I've worked with a
therapist, like I've worked
with a therapist.
- Yeah.
- And I've used meditation,
I've used prayer, my spirituality.
And I just want people to have something
that they find for themselves
that will really serve them.
So that we can-
- Be the best version.
- The best,
the best version of ourselves.
And be in joy.
I, I believe in joy.
- Yeah, me too.
- Yeah.
- I have something funny though.
So when you told your mom who loves
to cook soulful food,
like soul food, like...
- Yeah.
- That you were gonna be a vegan.
How'd that go over?
Was she like, wait, what?
- Well, first of all, she was like,
what are you talking about?
Like, when I didn't want to
eat the Turkey at Thanksgiving.
- Yeah.
- And the foods that I normally ate,
they were like in shock.
She was kind of like, she
felt like I rejected her.
And I understand, 'cause that was her way
of giving love, you know, like,
- Yeah.
- My son is coming home,
I'm working all over the time.
- And she spent a minute on that Turkey.
- She spent a minute on that,
she cooked the greens.
(Kelly laughs)
But once she saw I was for real about it,
you know, the next year, the next year,
then it was like, okay,
I gotta start cooking some
vegetarian food for this guy.
- Yeah.
- And she, she did it.
And it wasn't that good
at first, you know?
- Yeah.
- But-
- No, that's like me trying to bake
with all the like healthy
sugars, I'm like...
- Yeah, you gotta learn how to...
- Yeah.
- You gotta learn how to still-
- The chemistry of that, yeah.
- Let me say, because I know my mother's
watching, she has improved.
And, she's a very good vegan chef.
- Your mama is gonna whoop your ass.
- She's a very good-
- She's like, I have improved,
Okay?
- She is good, she's really good now.
- Do you cook, do you like cooking?
- No, I don't cook at all.
- I know.
- I mean, that's-
- I don't think you could be judging other
people's skills then. (laughs)
- I still know what tastes good,
you know what I'm saying?
- I'm like, look, I was like,
you know what this tastes like,
I didn't cook it, so
I'll put it in my mouth.
- I was like-
- Are you a good chef?
- No.
- Okay.
But you mentioned working out
and I think in your,
the first film you did is when you
really started getting fit.
So like what's on your like,
workout playlist, you got a playlist?
- My playlist, which I put in the,
I have a playlist in a book.
It's hiphop, It's hiphop.
- Yeah.
- It's like, for me it's nineties hiphop,
because that's what-
- Yeah 'cause, oh.
- That gave me the oomph.
- Nineties music in general.
- Like nineties music,
nineties R&B too.
- Yeah.
But like for me it's like,
- It's like Babyface all
over the place, oh yeah.
- But I can't work out to Babyface.
- No, no, but I mean, like, he like,
you know, he's such a great producer.
There's all those songs.
- All, yeah, yeah.
- He, like other producers singing
BGB, he's doing all of it, yeah.
- Yeah, but I love working out to like,
groups like Tribe Called Quest.
- Yeah.
- And De La Soul,
and Mob Deep and Pete Rock and Co Smooth.
Like, this is music that
just get me going and yeah.
And I never work out to my own songs.
- Oh my God, it's so funny.
People tell me all the time,
they're like, oh my God,
you're my workout playlist.
I'm like, I wish I worked out to it.
- I know, exactly.
(audience laughs)
- The only time I workout
to my music is on stage when I'm-
- Exactly.
- Huffing and puffing going,
you should probably work out more.
- Yeah.
- Like, yeah.
So we wanna also talk about,
so you're launching like a social
campaign also with the book, right?
- Yes, it's called "Make One Change."
Like one of my changes, I
love these turmeric lattes.
- Oh, me too.
- You like them?
- Yes.
- I love turmeric.
- I love turmeric, it's good.
But it's really great for you,
it's good for inflammation.
- I know, especially if you
mix it with Black pepper.
- Oh yeah, I haven't tried that, I gotta.
- Yeah, I get very science-y
sometimes with things,
but yeah, yeah.
- Really?
Do you read up on those things?
- Yes, but here's the thing,
I'm not so good at retaining,
so I have other people,
friends go read this with me.
And then they retain it and
then I'm reminded, yeah.
- Listen, I'm not mad at you because-
- I have selective memory.
- I'm not, I love reading,
but I have to say like,
some of the things that I've learned,
come from teachers, people
that have experienced it
and just like a lot of
the people in my book,
like, I just learned from 'em.
I just listened and learned.
So I get what you're saying about reading.
- I love, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I love learning.
One way we rise on our show
is through connection.
So we thought we'd do a new segment
where we share our takes on the most
controversial topics from past
episodes to see if we come
to a consensus on any.
This is...
♪ Finding ♪
♪ Common ground ♪
- Okay, runs.
Alright, Jesse with the runs.
Okay, so all we do is hit this
button and our supercomputer,
'cause it's totally
linked up to a computer.
We'll look back through
five seasons of shows
to find our most controversial subjects
or topics rather, then we're gonna try
to settle things on each topic.
We're gonna settle it
right here, are you ready?
- Okay, okay, I'm ready to settle it.
- All right, boom.
(box dings)
Well, don't be ready to settle.
That's not a way to live.
(both laugh)
Ooh.
Can, okay, okay.
This is, this one came up from
John Crier when I was talking to him.
And can you be friends with an ex?
- Yes, I could definitely
be friends with an ex.
I mean-
- Like, how long was the relationship?
- I mean, I've been friends
with a lot of exes that I've had
and they've been long relationships.
'cause most of 'em end pretty good.
I mean, we go through
stuff at the beginning
of the breakup, but then
once we come to our grounds,
it's like we both, we good
people, we cool people.
Are you friends with any of your exes?
- No.
(audience cheers)
I mean, here's the thing.
- Ain't no judgment, no judgment.
- I'm not, not friends.
But I feel, 'cause the, I'm cool with,
I only have a couple that
I'm just like, hard pass.
But, but no.
But you know, a couple of them though,
I don't have many exes,
but like a couple of them are cool people.
They're, nothing wrong with them.
There's, if we ran into each other,
we'd be totally friendly.
But that's the difference.
- If they invited you
to a party with like,
like they said, man, we having a party
for some of their family members.
I would, yeah, depending on the ex.
Yeah, no, I would be like,
okay, cool, yeah I'll show up.
Like I can, I just feel
like it can get awkward for,
it depends on who ended it or who it is.
And it's situational.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
But for mostly, no, no. (laughs)
I feel like that's awkward,
no common ground there, here we go.
(box dings)
- [Common] Spoken like
a true tourist, huh?
- I'm just being real.
(graphic dings)
Oh, this is interesting.
Brie Larsson, she brought this one up.
Because she, they like hot
dogs, she and her friends.
So, wait, it's whether
a hot dog is a sandwich.
I know you're from Chicago,
hot dogs are a big thing there.
I'm just saying it's meat and bread.
- It's not a sandwich.
It's called a hot dog for
a reason. (audience cheers)
- I love a hot dog.
- It's a hot dog.
I love, I eat veggie dogs
now and I love veggie dogs.
- I ain't ever had a veggie dog,
it doesn't sound sexy, but...
- We got some good ones right.
- Okay, okay, maybe I would try it.
- So is a hot dog a sandwich to you?
- I mean, here's the thing,
I never thought about
it until she said it.
And then I was like, well...
- But why would-
- Bread and meat
and the bread surrounds the meat.
That kinda sounds like a sandwich.
- No, no, no.
I mean, why wouldn't they
just call it a sandwich then?
- I don't know.
You might be right on
that one, I don't know.
- A pork, they would say a pork
link sandwich or something.
- Pork link sandwich.
Oh, I love a sausage roll.
- No, no, no, no.
- I'm so hungry right now.
(both laugh)
No common ground there, here we go.
(graphic dings)
Okay.
Oh, this is a hard one.
Wait, who should be considered
greatest rapper of all time?
That, who answers that?
Other than Common?
- Who should-
I'm gonna answer.
- I say Common.
- I'm gonna say, I'm gonna say me.
- I did say Common. (laughs)
(audience cheers)
- Hey, hey, I'm on my, hey, hey.
- That was on my answer.
- I'm on my, I'm on my,
I'm on my, I'm on my Niecy Nash.
My Niecy Nash, I'm gonna
give myself some thanks,
- Yeah, I love Niecy Nash
- And some love.
She, you know at the Emmys,
she gave herself some love.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna say I'm the
greatest rapper of all time.
Now if I take myself
outta that conversation,
then it's, for me, it is Nas, Rakim,
Big Daddy Kane, KRS-One who else?
- I said one man.
- Andre 3000.
I know, I gave you five.
- So, okay, so we have
common ground on that one,
I feel like, but Common's book is called,
"And Then We Rise", pick up a copy y'all.